-Salut Romain, ça va ?
-Oui, c'est quoi le sujet d'aujourd'hui ?
Ah ! Les règles.
Oh !
-Bah quoi ?
-Bah c'est dégueulasse.
-Bah non.
-Bah si.
-Bah... si.
-Bah non.
-Bah si.
-Bah pourquoi ?
[Générique]
Donc aujourd'hui on va parler des règles.
Parce qu'on va pas se mentir,
on entend dire tout et n'importe quoi sur ce sujet,
comme sur pas mal d'autres.
Avant de commencer je tiens à faire un petit disclaimer,
comme on dit sur internet,
si on est en l'an 2000.
DTC c'est une chaîne de vulgarisation,
donc l'idée c'est de simplifier les choses
et de parler des cas les plus courants
pour les rendre accessibles au plus grand nombre.
Mais, quand je vais parler des femmes et des règles,
gardez bien à l'esprit que les choses ne sont pas aussi binaires.
Toutes les femmes n'ont pas leur règles
et toutes les personnes qui ont leur règles ne sont pas des femmes.
Alors pour plein de raisons
et notamment dans le cas des personnes transgenres,
qui méritent évidemment une vidéo dédiée.
En attendant, pour le sujet du jour,
je vous renvoie au lien que je vous ai mis dans la description.
Cette précision étant faite,
je vous propose maintenant, de démonter quelques mythes et quelques mythos sur les menstruations.
Les règles, c'est sale.
Qu'est ce que c'est que cette matière ?
C'est... c'est de la merde ?
Alors non, c'est pas sale.
Mais on va détailler un peu quand même.
Les règles, c'est le résultat visible du cycle menstruel,
que les personnes qui possèdent un utérus connaissent entre la puberté et la ménopause.
En gros le corps se prépare régulièrement,
d'où le nom hein,
à une éventuelle fécondation.
Et il passe par plusieurs phases.
Il se passe plein de choses, notamment au niveau des hormones mais aussi de la paroi de l'utérus,
qui s'épaissit et qui se prépare,
au cas où elle aurait besoin d’accueillir un petit pensionnaire.
Et si finalement, personne ne vient s'installer,
on laisse tomber, on nettoie tout, jusqu'à la prochaine fois.
Du coup la couche superficielle de l'endomètre,
la muqueuse, qui tapisse l'intérieur de l'utérus,
elle se décolle, ça saigne un peu,
et tout ça est évacué par le vagin.
Bon mais alors du coup, est-ce que c'est sale ?
Y'a quoi là-dedans ?
Et bah du sang, donc, de la muqueuse, c'est à dire une espèce de peau et des trucs récupérés sur le trajet.
Genre la flore chargée de défendre le vagin contre les infections.
C'est à dire des bactéries, ok.
Mais des bactéries vous en avez un peu partout sur la peau pour vous protéger.
Celles la elles sont pas plus méchantes que les autres, et règles ou pas règles, elles sont là tout le temps.
Hein.
Et d'habitude ça dérange pas trop les gens qui rentrent en contact avec.
Donc, rien de sale là-dedans.
Euh, s'il vous plaît ?
Ah.
J'ai l'impression que notre menstruologue, Jack Parker, veut intervenir.
Alors non seulement c'est pas sale,
mais en plus, vu l'endroit où ça se trouve,
personne ne vous force à aller voir hein, ça va pas vous sauter à la gorge.
Les règles, ça pue.
[Vomissements]
Alors non, hein, en tout cas beaucoup moins que ce qu'on pense.
Et y'a des moyens pour empêcher ça.
De base, le sang menstruel,
Oui parce que les règles, ça s'appelle les menstruations,
et le sang,  ça s'appelle les menstrues.
Le sang menstruel donc,
il a son odeur, mais il sent pas mauvais.
Sauf, s'il est pas frais.
Mais ça c'est comme tout.
C'est comme la transpiration,
De base ça sent rien, mais si ça macère, ça sent un peu.
Le sang qui stagne, d'où qu'il vienne, ça sent.
Si on ajoute à ça, les substances rejetées par les bactéries,
qui en profitent que ça stagne pour proliférer,
et les produits contenus dans les protections,
si on garde tout ça un peu longtemps, ça sent.
Mais encore une fois on est d'accord, même dans ces cas là, c'est discret.
Et toute personne qui se tient à une distance socialement acceptable de la culotte concernée,
n'a aucune idée de ce qu'il s'y passe.
Mais, peut-être que Jack Parler a un conseil ?
Oui ! Lavez vous normalement, trop ça a tendance à aggraver les choses.
Et surtout, changez de protection toutes les 3 à 4 heures en moyenne, sauf la nuit, évidemment.
Quand on a ses règles, on en fout partout.
Alors les règles c'est 3 à 5 jours tous les 28 jours.
Mais ok, c'est pas aussi régulier que son nom pourrait le laisser penser.
Ça peut être plus, ça peut être moins, selon les personnes, mais surtout ça peut être irrégulier.
Du coup oui, dans l'absolu, ça peut arriver sans prévenir,
Mais y'a quand même quelques signes avant-coureurs qui font que, en général, on anticipe un petit peu le coup.
Et puis surtout on en fout pas partout parce qu'en moyenne,
la quantité de sang qui s'écoule, c'est 35 à 50 millilitres, sur toute la durée des règles.
On parle de règles abondantes à partir de 80 millilitres.
35 à 50 millilitres, ça fait entre 7 et 10 cuillères à café.
Voilà, 10 cuillères à café ça fait ça, hein.
Étalé sur plusieurs jours, donc y'a pas de quoi repeindre une pièce non plus hein.
Donc non, avoir ses règles,
ça ne veut pas dire se transformer en un geyser de sang incontrôlable.
Non.
Il y a surtout des protections hygiéniques adaptées aux différents flux,
une fois qu'on a trouvé celles qui conviennent, sauf accident, ça devrait pas poser problème.
Les femmes sont chiantes quand elles ont leur règles.
Alors essayons de voir les choses de manières à la fois concrète et objective.
Le cycle menstruel entraîne des modifications hormonales importantes.
La progestérone par exemple, elle augmente, puis elle chute brutalement juste avant les règles,
ce qui peut avoir des répercussions sur l'humeur, donc sur le moral.
Un peu comme après un accouchement.
Mais il peut y avoir aussi toute une batterie de répercussions physiques,
qui font que ce n'est pas précisément le moment le plus confortable du mois.
Le syndrome pré-menstruel, apparaît plusieurs jours avant les règles,
avec son cortège de symptômes comme :
Des douleurs abdominales, dans le dos ou dans les seins.
Des troubles digestifs, de la fatigue, des problème de peau,
des troubles du sommeil, des maux de tête, des bouffées de chaleur, et cetera.
En théorie, tout ça, ça disparaît plus ou moins au moment de l'arrivée des menstruations,
mais ça laisse sa place aux diverses sensations liées au flux.
Ça c'est la raison pour laquelle les personnes qui ont ou qui vont avoir leurs règles
ne se sentent pas forcément au mieux.
Les troubles sont plus ou moins forts selon les individus mais attention,
se sentir mal, ça n'est pas être chiant
ou chiante
D'abord parce que ça, c'est un jugement,
et ensuite parce que ça implique des relations, hein,
donc des interactions avec d'autre personnes.
En l’occurrence, ce qui est sûr, c'est que dans tous les cas, un peu d'empathie ça fait jamais de mal.
À l'inverse, les allusions répétées et plus ou moins fines aux règles et à l'état nerveux, ça n'aide pas vraiment.
Non.
Donc non, les personnes qui ont leur règles ne sont pas chiantes,
elles sont juste potentiellement en train de morfler.
Soyez aussi cool avec elles qu'avec une personne qu'aurait une rage de dent par exemple, hein.
Parce qu'en plus là c'est tout les mois.
-Ah, et aussi,
-Ne mettez pas tout sur le compte des règles.
Si une personne vous envoie chier, c'est peut-être parce qu'elle supporte moins bien les trucs pénibles que d'habitude,
mais c'est peut-être aussi parce que les trucs pénibles, c'est pénible, justement.
Avoir des rapports sexuels pendant les règles, c'est dangereux.
Bon, alors là, soyons clairs, non pas du tout.
On l'a déjà vu, les menstrues, c'est pas sale,et ce qu'on trouve à l'intérieur,
c'est pas fondamentalement différend de ce qu'il y a dans le secteur d'habitude.
Alors ok, il y a du sang en plus, et quand on pense au sang,
on pense aux maladies sexuellement transmissibles.
Et oui.
Mais en réalité ça change absolument rien à la situation.
Soit on est dans le cas d'un couple et les deux partenaires ont fait leur dépistage,
tout est clean, auquel cas, pas de problème.
Soit les deux partenaires quels qu'ils soient, ne sont pas dépistés,
et là, règles ou pas règles, on se protège.
Donc ça change rien.
En plus niveau quantité de sang, on l'a vu, on est loin du Vésuve.
Donc pour l'hygiène, je vous laisse voir ça entre vous, juste,
si la protection est à l'intérieur du vagin,
genre tampon, voile, cup, éponge, et cetera ;
petit conseil, retirez la juste avant tout ce qui est pénétration.
C'est quand même mieux.
Donc médicalement parlant, on peut avoir des rapports sexuels pendants les règles sans problème,
ça n'est ni dangereux, ni sale.
C'est chacun son choix, quand on veut, comme on veut,
et on a le droit de changer d'avis d'un cycle à l'autre ou d'un jour à l'autre.
Voilà je crois qu'on a vu le principal, mais juste,
pour être sûr d'avoir vraiment fait le tour des bullshits ;
Non ! Le sang des règles n'est pas bleu.
Malgré ce que la pub essaye de vous faire croire.
Oui ! On peut préparer de la mayonnaise quand on a ses règles.
Sauf si on est nul en cuisine comme moi, mais ça c'est un autre problème.
En tout cas ça empêche pas la mayonnaise de monter.
Ça fait pas tourner le lait non plus.
Et ça transforme pas le vin en vinaigre.
Voilà, on a démonté quelques mythes et quelques mythos sur les règles.
Pour le reste, je vous renvoie au livre de Jack Parker
et à son blog "Passion Menstrues" dont je vous met les références dans la description de cette vidéo.
Voilà DTC c'est fini pour aujourd'hui,
pas de panique, on revient très vite pour de nouvelles vidéos,
d'ici là écoutez, bah, mettez-vous bien et puis surtout, portez-vous bien.
Je vais pas vous le dire à chaque fois hein ?
Si peut-être, si.
[Générique]